you
[Music]
welcome to the second season of Mars I
am Samuel TV I play rubber for car and
this is a beautiful
Clementine for that sand I play dr.
Emily Johan and we are in our beautiful
studio in Hungary at court last video
which is like one of the biggest studio
in Europe I think yes it is and also
quarter is named after one of the young
Guerin directors from back in the 1920s
I believe our big stage yeah that's
amazing
this season is even bigger than the last
season last season was kind of compacted
now we have a big stage more space and
we're going to show you some stuff
yeah from olympus town which is now home
on mars and as you can see we haven't a
Martian not a marshal he's a Martian is
working and oh this look like a basalt
rock yeah Martian rock
yeah Martian rock and also we got some
new friends here Mars this season and
are we really friends I mean I've never
been invited I don't really know them
well I would say this is a perfect time
to meet the crew from Lutron colony
let's go welcome from Olympus town you
are now entering the Luke Rome colony
what's that nothing it's our colony
absolutely hi guys my name is Roxy
Steinbeck and I'm playing Jen Carson in
season 2 of Mars my name is Jeff Hebner
and I'm playing commander Curt her L in
season 2 of Mars and we represent like
we said the luke room colony and and
projecting forward what's gonna happen
on mars when we get there at some point
we're gonna have to turn a profit we're
gonna have to mine it for its resources
and we represent that that part of the
story yep we're the new guys and this is
our bus
so this is where we basically dictate to
the miners out there what we'd like them
to do this is where you and Shep Spanish
where I kind of end this is where you
come and that is green screen out there
that is where the wonderful Mars will be
my surface it's lovely isn't it lovely
darling love those green dots moving on
shall we yes
Oh to a room in which we've never shot
no we've never shot in here but I'm
excited to see what its gonna be
what do you think it's gonna be I think
it's gonna be what do I think it's gonna
be or what do I want it to be what do
you want I want it to be the party break
I know so the airlock the airlock rooms
the loudest Broome answer between the
loudest room on set have you had it yeah
I was out there in Palau so between
leaving my surface and entering the
Airbus these little silver things will
blow out carbon dioxide and that will
basically clean us so that we don't
contaminate the Airbus and when we're
really actually are on Mars probably not
you and me but real miners this I have a
practical function you know when you're
out there stirring up different
compounds and dirts and things that we
have no idea really what's in them yet
until we get there they're gonna have to
wash it off you spray it off so you
don't bring it into the colony because
it could could infect it could make
people sick it could screw up the
computers a bunch of stuff I don't know
anything about yeah it's a great room
it's just look and so doors open please
pretty please with a cherry on top oh
look at that you had it it pretty please
oh gosh so there's no gravity in this
bit so this is where we know just me
just you ah the control room yes mhm
this is where we control things and
command them cuz that's what I do I'm a
commander yes are you coming in with
that stuff again you think it's funny
don't you no oh it's not no seriously
though on it has a practical function
this as a set for actors is kind of
stunning a dream it's the whole set
we're off to working in half rooms
where the walls ripped off and cameras
poked through and when you're trying to
find an emotional mindset working on
Mars it really helps to have a set like
this that's complete with heft yeah
feels like we have something to work
with absolutely go pretend I'm our
detail it really is yeah oh and then
here's the canteen yes couple people
sleeping as you would this is all like
food
chill out are in our area mm-hmm this is
the one place on purpose has this beat
because they have an actual bar yeah but
we've got proper chairs that's right
you'll put it back there bars like
garbage cans tipped over where we eat
moss food right sure yeah yeah sure it's
delicious
can you speak mars yet by the way I can
but I don't want to show up
[Music]
now but really from from an actor's
point of view coming to a set like this
where there are four walls and you can
actually feel like you're in a control
room it's really special
what is Steven Patrick the man who
literally wrote the book on how we live
on Mars stepped in here and was just
like this is how it's gonna look this is
what it'll be
and that also informs you know how
you're gonna do your job you're gonna be
like well this it gives it a sense of
realism mm-hmm and more realism we're in
the medical Bay yeah
and again as a practical function when
people are mining and doing it heavy
industrial work on Mars it's dangerous
just like it would be here and even more
so because there's so many unknowns so
there'll be a medical bay it'll be
equipped with doctors and you and
obviously and and the advanced equipment
you would need to take care of somebody
when there's no real hospital nearby I
mean it's amazing am i comfortable to
memory-foam guys I hope you've enjoyed
our tour of the Luke chram colony and
you can now go back to Olympus town not
quite as fun and feel free to enjoy a
virtual tour but we're not gonna be here
anymore yeah I'm done but um yeah I hope
you've enjoyed our tour here at Calder
Studios in Budapest Hungary hungry how
long are you hungry okay let's go have
lunch see ya see ya bye such an easy job
I think I've done it like place it's not
funny it's Oh get off
doors open please
pretty please with a cherry on top and
now we're in the control room in Olympus
and with special guests yes we have one
of the creative genius behind this
wonderful set mr. Adrian Smith how are
you sir pleasure to have you with us do
you want to introduce us to your cohorts
your friends here yes yes on my right
here I have Thomas load-in who is one of
our art directors in charge of the la
creme set and all things scientific been
a great resource and design of the whole
sets here and on my left who's James
morale who is in charge of all the
special props and has been doing some
sterling work some fantastic work that's
great now if you guys have any questions
that you want to find out about the
guide this link post our command center
or any any of the other places you've
seen you should please write in and
we'll be able to answer your questions
to the best of our abilities I have a
question for you specific possible that
you guys decided to like create a look
from colony cooler than our colony
well we've been here on this planet for
nine years
oh my god I don't want to be in your
shoes buddy come on I mean you you guys
you guys work for you know government
agencies so yeah there's this there's a
bit of kind of taxpayer money involved
you can't be looking to be too
comfortable here but you know the
money's gone in where it counts you know
the money's gone into things like the
lab and lokrum is a private owned
company exactly you know so we you know
this is the control center as you guys
can see we've got little screens that
they've added this season it's a lot
bigger than last season by
it's it's small you know it's more
beautiful you guys have done a great job
I would love for you guys I also want to
share with our fans out there if you
could tell us some of this stuff and on
the screen if you want to you know
elaborate well basically we've designed
this is the control center for all the
operations yes
Olympus town this is where commander
Hannes song this is our desk and that's
mine by the way because I'm only a
doctor well no you're not only a doctor
you have your own medical Bay which
we're gonna go to later but yes and
around you you see the various functions
of the control center we've got our
nuclear power plant monitoring system
over there the water generation system
over there communications system there
and also the sort of fuel processing
system in the background there and this
is all kind of coordination controlled
by the character Hannah's character yes
so we've got our question from our
audience what kind of experts did you
consult to come up with all these
futuristic equipment well good question
the first thing is you basically we we
lead that kind of that search so we look
into a lot of papers from NASA a lot of
papers from all sorts of sources as well
and then one of the main things we then
do is we we run it past our specific
tech experts who Steven who you know as
I say wrote the book and then also on
Bobby Brown who's who's one of our
specific experts as well and I really
like this question it says did you take
any influence from pop culture sci-fi
for your set designs
no not specific because this is very
unusual project in terms of design
because we are actually designing for
real science or projected real science
so rather than usually where it's just
your imagination
is just unlimited here we're actually
turning projected real science but
trying to make it look interesting and
exciting visually alright we'll take one
more question and I would like to ask
you this what is it like acting on a set
that completely surrounds you well you
you feel like you dive in I mean it's so
much easier for us to have like specific
things on the screens and like
everything is so detailed and and
through we are surrounded and we're it's
very round
there's something very homey I feel that
it is it is it's it's quite you know
it's it's not like my house but I feel
comfortable and everything is so
detailed
everything is so precise the corridors
are like endless so it's easy to get
lost I mean but thank you for that guys
because it's it's very helping us
because in between action and cut I
really do believe them that I'm an
astronaut on Mars and that you know I'm
so it's great thank you for that I know
why don't we since you guys have asked
questions you see some of these faces
why don't we take you to show you the
video of the design process of what
these guys came up with and let's check
it out
these are some of the common spaces that
we've designed for Olympus town this is
the bass throat garden area that's
designed as a recreation area for the
people that living in olympus town
interestingly the bar and all its
contents from elements that have been
recycled things like the bar itself is
actually an element a fairing from
original
ship that came and delivered the stuff
to Mars plants planted with a very
minimal watering system because
obviously in water is very precious on
Mars and the pathways you see they're
all created from regolith which is
reconstituted Marjan terrain that's so
the idea is that everything has been
recycled and reused and the whole thing
is covered over with a very large dome
that actually give you the sort of sense
of being enclosed now the corridors
these are used or re reused we've
recycled them ourselves from the first
series they've been updated they've had
new lighting system new graphics
additional pipe work it's very much been
and that you know we try to actually
give the sense that there has been life
here in this corridor system for the
last sort of nine years so there's a lot
of detail there ageing and giving it a
sense that it has actually been lived in
rather than a brand-new environment
welcome to martyrs lab this is one of
the other spaces here Mars on on our set
this is actually one of the biggest labs
this is one of the biggest spaces
actually on this set I think a new built
it's a not-guilty I did I mean he's
character building not handler thing not
him I'm looking at Martha's samples from
Mars I mean I shouldn't do it too much
now like this are some of the findings
of some of the stuff that she found
while on the Mars surface trying to find
possibility of life on Mars and you know
as you can see in this petri dish I
don't know what that is blue cheese from
France blue cheese from France no no I
wouldn't know I don't think so I mean
this is some like scary looking thing I
don't know what this is but I'm gonna
put it down because Marta is very
particular about her stuff also this is
called a DNA sequencer Wow Wow we've got
it and I think James can tell us what
it's for what what he actually does I'm
gonna actually take you guys over here
and show you this DNA sequencer and can
you help us out kind of I hope the fans
and tell us what this is what what he
does but obviously at the end of the
first season they had discovered
microbial life on Mars and one of the
major things that you'd need to do in
that situation is begin to understand
exactly how that creature came to be on
that planet and what it's made of and
finding its genome and beginning to find
whether or not it has any similarities
with life on Earth it would be
incredibly important yeah and I have
another question for you because over
there I see a weird blue silver machine
recreation electron microscope which is
one of the most sensitive devices we
have to look at the atomic structure of
something to actually get down and look
at you know how its molecules made and
to find out you know exactly how these
creatures are constructed what they're
made of at a complete you know subatomic
level it's really beautiful
hey Julia it's a rebirth of Mars now
this is just to show you how big this
place is
I mean it's this is the second level of
this lab and it's built by Tom what
about creative geniuses will design this
lab and also build the look from our
colony could you tell us a little bit
about this the stage this lab well the
the main thing actually that you've sort
of stumbled on by walking up there when
you've got a dome like that a dome is a
very very strong structure the idea is
that it's made of big segments of
regolith accrete on the outside so it's
actually 3d printed using regolith from
the surface but you have this big
geodesic dome and a problem with the
geodesic dome is you've got this huge
amount of space at the top which is
completely wasted and when you're on on
Mars and air is precious you don't want
to be filling a huge dome with air and
not using it so the second story
actually gives you kind of makes it a
bit more efficient in that you're you're
using all the pressurized space in that
dome rather than just everyone being
down on the ground level I'm needing
them twice as many domes
now we have a question for one of our
audience members what kind of science is
supposed to be happening in this lab
I'll field that one basically they are
the sequencing the genome of the
bacteria that they found beginning of
the first season they're finding out
exactly what it's made from
is it a carbon-based life-form like us
is it based on silicon can interact with
our biochemistry does it pose a threat
is it toxic
can they even make it breed when they
find it it's been in hibernation for who
knows how long and they're attempting to
discover exactly what circumstances led
to it being below the surface of Mars
and we've got another question here what
are some of the actors favorite props
you can answer that well my favorite
props will be my favorite bar which
we're gonna get to later on prop it's
probably the EBS ooh I love that the
helmet oh yeah that'd be a suit the
season is amazing
it's totally different from last season
and a helmet by the way which is all
designed by a wonderful Katherine Harris
Caroline heiress excuse me
on their note I think that we should
probably have a look at the personal
spaces now yes these are some of the
personal spaces in the Olympus town
this is Javier's workshop next to the
Hydra room and as you can see there's a
lot of dressing very kind of complicated
equipment that Xavier as an engineer has
and we've researched that quite
thoroughly a lot of very specialist
tools that have been we've created to
actually kind of use on Mars and just
through the door there you can see the
equipment that we've designed that it's
based on a recreation of a water plant
that will actually be used in space on
Mars it's a very interesting kind of use
of the dome or the two domes actually
join merge together really this is
Xavier and Amelia's habitation joint
habitation again what we've done is
joined two of the smaller domes together
and as you can see is quite a lot of
built-in furniture that's been designed
to actually fill fill and fit into the
dome shape and there are a certain
element of personal personal things for
the various kind of characters we are
very limited to how much we can actually
you know how much you can actually take
to Mars so each of these items is very
precious and their are very kind of
carefully chosen as part of the
decoration of the sets and welcome to my
kingdom my medical lab yeah
I'm a doctor and the therapist here so
we've got some a doctor I think is doing
me wrong doctor okay I did a good
checked okay so we show you we have a
super futuristic scanner I can see
pretty much whatever Sammy has been
doing for the last 24 hours to 48 hours
sorry so can you help us guys like
talking about this multifunctional
scanner looking at what current medical
technology is doing and that you know
engineers and doctors are trying to
incorporate all the different diagnostic
equipment that we currently have into
one machine so we started off looking at
ways that you could have a CT scanner an
x-ray machine a cat scan and ultrasound
and general diagnostic sort of you know
machine in a reasonably compact sort of
piece of equipment that you could
conceivably ship to Mars because at the
moment you know the size of a real
entire room just for one of these
machines but in 20 or 30 years time you
know you better put it in a shipping
crate and send it halfway across the
solar system now what I want to know is
what does this machine into what is this
what is he used for this I believe is
drafting could you explain to the
audience what this what it does yeah
you've got back there is medical 3d
printer which can either print things
like casts and sprints for broken bones
or be reconfigured to print you know a
biological scaffold for growing skin
grafts or you know even some you know
soft tissues you know for any kind of
injury burns whatever you could possibly
face if you listen here they could print
it out here absolutely yeah they could
print in 3d and ear or like some tissue
what you do is you the idea is that you
print
scaffold which you'd then seed with stem
cells from you know the patient's own
body and then you would you know culture
new tissue new skin on it and then you
could actually transplant it onto yeah
that patient now we've got a question
from our audience what elements of a
real lab are represented here quarantine
think decontamination order pretend
safety features well we have a
quarantine room over there and and also
like all the medical stuff that we
actually need and I think it looks quite
good and the lab works pretty well I'm
saving lives that's you saving lives
she's sitting in our lives
oh no no why don't we good to be why
don't we show you guys the design
process for this ok the design process
generally starts with the script reading
the script and meeting with director and
producer and from that as a production
designer you start to produce very loose
mood boards and conceptual designs and
part of the process then is actually
refining these they then get passed on
down into the art department to the
various kind of our directors who then
start to refine your designs part of the
process then is to start creating some
of the specific props on the show like
this a lot of the items in it are based
on real science and have to be accurate
in terms of not only the science but the
way they look and in this you can see
James is trying on a 3d printed arm cast
that has been created and the
by the 3d printers you can see them
there we've got three of them there that
just been working 24/7 right the way
through the production producing some
amazing 3d parts and we're in the
workshop here the pop workshop and you
can see there one of the specialized
props we created it's a very interesting
and future bound prop that works well
within the whole story
well welcome this is actually my
favorite place because I designed it he
built it and with my my colleague Ivo
Delgado and I would say we did an
amazing job this is yeah and that Lucan
calling me they don't have that they
don't have a bar no you don't have a bar
oh now no we're gonna take some
questions yeah I think which is a very
good question that says do they
manufacture all the equipment on Mars or
do they get it from Earth I think you'll
be expensive to bring the equipment from
or items from from Earth so we have to
manufacture all these stuff that you see
around here and also to give you a good
example of that is if you look at some
of this come with me if you look at some
of these trays they actually recycle
trays use as a tabletop also this is
like dust bins and we just got creative
and everything that you see here is
recycled and stuff that we we we found
from here so we actually told the green
up here and what about what we drink
well the drinks are also like made from
like for example one of my favorite
drink is a potato vodka which I made and
basically everything at the bar you do I
did it I mean you know and also we have
refined a little distillery back there
and we also make our own beer yeah Mars
beers Mars beer sorry the way I have a
question for Adrian and the boys
do you think that it would be possible
to have to make wine here to have a
vineyard here on Mars well we're going
to look at the local videos next week
see we can find you know why no Mars
let's take a couple of questions one of
them someone says how often do your
characters come to the bar well as often
as possible I don't I don't I'm very
serious
Yeah right you know we we got it we got
to take time off from doing research and
doing the work and I think what a
perfect place to come and relax as you
can see it it's big and we've got a dome
and also Adrian I believe there's a way
that we can turn it into date daylight
and also bring the night time to it as
well yes the Olympus town is actually at
the bottom of a lava tube underground
and the idea is that the dome is
actually has an integrated lighting
system which gives an artificial
daylight and then can be turned off
evening and night
all right that's right I think we should
plan some karaoke nights I think that'd
be really nice and someone asked are the
plants on Mars real yeah well basically
that's what we try to do we're trying to
tell from this planet to make it
habitable we want to be able to plant
vegetables and grow our own vegetables
and and and plants and to be able to
make our own food and and recycle use
recycled items and and that's basically
what we're doing building this colony
and it's got another question what's the
most and I think it's for you Adrian and
the boys what's the most fanciful or
sci-fi part of your designs hmm probably
the probably the bit you're in well I
really love my hab we have yet I mean
we've got a great have with
king-size bed well I haven't seen it so
I can't say I wasn't invited oh let's
see one more question we've answered
that let's see the pen yes we just
answer that let's see what else oh you
know what does our character have a
favorite drink yeah you just said that
my favorite my favorite my favorite
drink is the potato vodka you know and I
make everything back there so if you
ever ventured to Mars please come to my
bar drinks all kinds of concussion out
here you know I've basically the brain
of the Olympus town to be honest with
you
you want to come on he's not is not
we're all together we are trying to be
one brain and that's on that no we want
to thank you guys for joining us on this
wonderful tour hope you guys enjoyed it
as much as we did and see you in 2018
2018 spring of 2018 season to Mars is
gonna be even greater than the first
season because there's so much more to
see there's so much more to experience
and it's it's cinematic
it's amazing we have a great new cows
that just join the show and it's it's
it's a thrilling ride and we want to
invite you to join us so thank you very
much for being a part of this and we
hope to see you in 2018 in this spring
[Music]